yes good job meatlug here you go darlin
mine's worth 10 yeah the black sheet now
I can stop me now except for me we're
attached genius quit trying to tell you
all my glory it's my glory always just
kind of want something that's just a
little deeper really yeah yeah deva
kings buy me a coat oh snap man we still
say the same thing this is amazing
carrots pumping neighbors glow sticks
twitter so sad a crazy we have that
brother Jan what was the message Santino
had for you
about a month ago middle of the night I
thought I heard noises in my house that
you what come on no I don't lie to me
give you see that guy with the gun out
there there's slowly goes because let's
get out of the corn time we're about to
break it in that your idea cuz I don't
care I'm old I've already look long
enough you ever really bad how about
having these conversations the wrong
time I want to come clean to you or me
to make a mess sir can I talk to you for
a second please news meet with me it was
me